you know another conspiracy theory is
that the schools not just colleges and
high schools but middle schools and
elementary schools are indoctrinating
our kids into weird creepy sex stuff
that's a conspiracy theory it's not
happening
it's good that it is happening they tell
us but also it's not happening at all
well
i have a report out from the daily
caller maryland elementary school
invites kids to pledge allegiance to the
pride flag
in elementary school
pta invited students to be recorded
pledging allegiance to the gay pride
flag according to a post on the school
pta page
this is the montgomery county public
schools cedar grove elementary school
they announced that the school quote
will be celebrating love respect and
tolerance with a video compilation of
students holding the pride flags and
saying the words love respect freedom
tolerance equality
and pride
the conservatives some conservatives are
going to say this is crazy this is nuts
get get all the sexual talk out of the
schools get all of the talk about belief
systems out of the schools get all the
religion get all of the values get all
of that out of the schools but of course
that's not possible
it's not possible to do that
because there's no such thing as
neutrality and education doesn't happen
in a vacuum the whole point of education
is that you teach people things not just
reading writing and arithmetic but about
what's good and what's bad and how they
should behave and what's normal and
what's natural and the kind of behaviors
that they should pursue frankly even the
conversation about sex education it
doesn't always have to be the creepy
stuff that they teach in the modern sex
ed classes even when when a teacher
reads a little book about mama bear and
papa bear
and little baby bear they are teaching
you something about family about about
sex actually they're teaching you
something about the way that that boys
and girls and men and women relate to
one another and and so no one would
object i mentioned this on the show a
few weeks ago no one would object to a
kindergarten teacher reading their
students a story about mama bear and
papa bear and baby bear we would all
object to a teacher reading his or her
students a story about mama bear and
papa bear and papa bear's boyfriend and
papa bear's boyfriend's three-legged
goat that he has a relationship with we
would all object to that because it's
the substance that matters here the kids
are going to pledge allegiance to
something
they can either pledge allegiance to the
american flag and traditional american
views and beliefs and traditions or they
can pledge allegiance to the cultural
revolutionaries and the gay pride flag
and diversity equity
and inclusion and all the cultural
radicalism but you've got to pick one
they are going to believe
something the conspiracy theory there's
a crazy conspiracy theory that that
students are being exposed to
pornography in schools not just pledging
allegiance to some weird sexual ideology
but their actual pornography that's not
true that's not happening you right
wingers are making this up there was a
parent at a colorado school board
meeting
who pulled out a book it's a very
popular book it's in school libraries
across the country the book is called
genderqueer take a listen
these two books that are on the poster
are lawn boy and genderqueer i will say
that i'm i do not favor book banning i
want to tell you that off the bat
but i do want to tell you that
pornography does not belong
in our schools or accessible
to our children
i got a new strap-on harness today i
can't wait to put it on you it will fit
my favorite dildo perfectly i can't wait
to have your car in my mouth i'm going
to give you the job of your life then i
want you inside me sorry you're out of
order this is your first warning
this
this is a book that is that is
accessible in adam's 12.
so kindly refrain from further
reading here please thank you this is
what you allow in our schools and this
is what you allow
for our kids to have access to this is
pornography and this is grooming for
pedophilia
please give me my time back
it's in the schools
it's in the school they say you're out
of order well if i'm out of order why
because i'm reading the book well then
the book is out of order if it's out of
order for adults why on earth would you
expose this to kids who are in our
schools
well i'm sorry that's i'm not going to
answer you it's just that's out of order
the reason that the school board is
upset here
is not because of the obscene content of
the book it's because the parent is
exposing the obscene content of the book
to the people to the parents of this
district who are shocked and appalled by
this as they as they obviously should be
that's just a conspiracy theory though
right uh i don't think so
so all it's all a crazy conspiracy
theory this weird sex stuff is a loser
for democrats the reason that they're so
keen on saying it's a conspiracy theory
and shutting it up and censoring it and
taking away the microphone at the school
board meeting is because they know that
this is a loser at the ballot box it's a
winner in the long term if the left can
totally reshape sexual moraes and can
push especially their sexual radicalism
because sex is so important to human
nature then it can really help them to
reshape society so it's a good long-term
strategy if they want to upend society
but it's a really crappy short-term
strategy because people hate it and it's
weird and they want to protect their
kids did you like that clip i'm glad you
did make sure you ring that smash and
like that subscribe and click that
doodad and hit the gizmo that way you
will get all of the notifications for
the michael knowles show you should also
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts make sure you head on over
there and subscribe to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you